[Musique]
bonjour marie les torpilles
non jérôme à ce viol temps bonjour aux
auditrices aux auditeurs de martinique
la première conseillère exécutive en
charge du développement économique de
l'emploi et de l'aide aux entreprises ça
tombe bien puisque dans quelques jours
l'entrepreneuriat s'expose ce sera la
deuxième édition de cette manifestation
pour les chefs d'entreprise et pour leur
dire mais que le futur s'entreprend dès
aujourd'hui tout à fait oui
effectivement c'est toi jours trois
jours que nous aurons pour ce salon rose
et je tiens vraiment à dire que c'est ce
sera papa l'a fait mais tout je dirais
tous les états de l'entreprise seront
vus et revus pour permettre à au chef
d'entreprise est aussi aux créateurs aux
porteurs de projets de leur trouver des
réponses à leurs questions
parce qu'il faut encore trouver des
réponses lorsqu'on est chef d'entreprise
lorsqu'on veut lorsqu'on a une idée
lorsqu'on un projet qu'on veut se lancer
oui oui par ailleurs je croyais qu'on
est en 2010 de shabé tout le monde
savait tout on est super bien formés on
note surtout non non mais vous savez la
réglementation prenant simplement cet
aspect là la réglementation change on
assure qu'on appelle la rgpp des tout le
monde en parle mais qu'est ce qu'est ce
que c'est quelle est l'implication et
comment comment faut-il traiter ce cette
nouvelle réglementation dans
l'entreprise par exemple les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
tous les chefs d'entreprise qui qui ont
une communication sur facebook ou sur
instagram ou sur qui twitte et tous ces
aspects là seront vus pendant ce salon
durera des ateliers des conférences plus
de 150 animations de la naissance dans
l'entreprise de l'idée même de lancer
l'entreprise jusqu'à la passation de
cette entreprise éventuellement des
héritiers tout à fait tout à fait toutes
les étapes de l'entreprise de la
création passant par le développement la
transmission mais aussi des aspects très
plus je dirais plus particuliers comme
le numérique nous avons un thème fort
que nous allons développer que la
transformation numérique des entreprises
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui
fonctionne je dirais de façon très
classe et très traditionnel oui c'est
pas seulement martinique un an
c'est la même chose que c'est une cause
nationale et donc on a besoin que les
chefs d'entreprise puissent se prendre
vraiment où tous les outils numériques
tout l'équipement les logiciels qui sont
à leur disposition pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que il améliore
leur organisation mais aussi l'eau ça
peut être leur production leur
fabrication enfin bon il faut qu'ils
utilisent ça pour monter en
compétitivité voulait tout simplement
dire qu'il faut que chaque entreprises
martiniquaises grandisse un peu et qu'il
ya des outils mais oui mais mais là où
c'est important c'est que si nous
prenons vraiment ce chemin nous arrivons
à faire et à créer chez nous de l'emploi
mais de l'emploi qualifié et hautement
qualifiés plus vous mettez de la
technologie dans votre activité
plus vous aurez besoin de se dé des
salariés qu'ils soient qualifiés qui
sont qualifiés pour pouvoir donc
répondre à votre votre fabrication
non il ne suffit pas de dire oui et nos
jeunes s'en vont et ne reviennent pas
ils reviendront s'ils nous si nous
sommes en capacité d'avoir sur notre
territoire des emplois qualifiés et
hautement qualifiés est ce que les chefs
d'entreprises et on a à peu près trente
mille en martinique est ce que ces chefs
d'entreprises connaissent forcément
toutes les étapes de la vie de leurs de
leur société est ce que ce sont des gens
qui ont ce parcours fléché en tête où il
découvre au fur et à mesure et c'est
peut-être là c'est peut-être là
finalement que le bât blesse
oui mais ce que moi j'ai constaté depuis
que je suis en fonction
c'est que au niveau de l'entreprise il
ya beaucoup de ces la méthode
d'entreprendre qui n'est pas bonne on ne
peut pas entreprendre une je dirais peut
pas entreprendre un projet si on n'a pas
un minimum d'apport en capital
entreprendre avec un euro dans sa peau
ce n'est pas possible ça va qu'il y a
déjà tellement basses idées non meublé
fait des autres des grenadines nationale
étasunienne est essentiellement qu'on
peut lancer son affaire depuis le garage
de papa et de maman a oui mais non non
non non c'est pas possible il ya
vraiment une méthode à respecter si on
veut que son entreprise plus je dirais
bien
bien prospéré après on est on est on
crée beaucoup d'entreprises en
martinique on est effectivement un peu
en dessous de la moyenne mais aussi nous
nous avons beaucoup d'entreprises qui se
meurt avant trois ans
donc on n'est pas bon dans je dirais
dans la la qualité de l'entreprise
et c'est là que c'est là que le bât
blesse c'est à dire que il faut de la
méthode il faut bien savoir faire il y à
des aides il y à des dispositifs mais
mal utilisé ils ne savent à une servent
arrière et six organismes qui sont là
comme les chambres consulaires les
organismes de fonctionnement fonctionne
de les organismes de formation les
écoles de commerce qui forment nos
étudiants ils ont pas ils ont toujours
on est tous là et tous on joue notre
hall et on joue vraiment parfaitement
leur rôle tout maintenant c'est d'avoir
cette coordination entre nous et c'est
aussi l'une des choses que qu'au niveau
de martine développement juste après le
salon que nous allons mettre en place le
réseau des accompagnateurs c'est pour
que tous les accompagnateurs plus avant
une visibilité et une lisibilité dans
leurs démarches pour que au niveau de
l'entreprise que celui qui à son projet
sache déjà
vers qui aller tout le monde fait mais
des fois on même lire ya même quelques
doublons sur le territoire alors que il
faut simplement qu'on arrive à être
efficace les dispositifs sont là mais tu
as toujours bien utilisé et est ce qui
donne cette perte au niveau des
entreprises alors l'entrepreneuriat qui
s'exposent ce sera l'occasion de faire
en sorte que tout le monde de ce rock
contribue peut être l'occasion de sortir
de certains clichés certes est de sortir
de cette morosité ambiante
il s'agit de dire tout simplement
amérique il ya des aides que tout le
monde y ait accès à condition d'être
vigilants il faut il faut effectivement
bien savoir les utiliser et bien bien
s'en approprier en fin de compte vous
avez au niveau de l'entreprise ce côté
de ces d'abord aussi souvent je le dis
c'est d'abord une action privée est
derrière vous avez tous je dirais tout
l'environnement qui est qui peut être
favorable et que nous faisons en sorte
aujourd'hui au niveau de la collectivité
de faire que cet environnement soit
favorable avec tous les partenaires
donc c'est vraiment je dirais on est
mobilisé autour de l'entreprise
c'est l'entreprise qui créera de
l'emploi ça on en est persuadé
et aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que nous
sommes je dirais plus plus plus
vigilants mais plus plus confiant parce
que nous sommes persuadés que nous
tenons le bon bout comme audi au niveau
de la ctm de la collectivité
nous avons aujourd'hui je dirais tout
tout panel d'accompagnement d'un
dispositif qui rend et je tiens à le
dire parce qu'il ya beaucoup de régions
en france qui n'ont pas le panel que
nous avons sur l'innovation sur le
numérique sur des par exemple ddd sur
des prêts à taux zéro que nous faisons
sur les prêts que nous avons mis en
place avec la bp sur les subventions
on a tout un panel aujourd'hui qui
devrait nous permettre de venir vraiment
en soutien à notre écosystème
il ne s'agit pas seulement de vendre du
rêve marie des torpilles parce que les
auditeurs ceux qui veulent entreprendre
vous entendent ils vont se précipiter à
la 7è ils auront une réponse oui alors
nous avons non en gaz mais oui tout à
fait nous recevons c'est ce que l'on
peut nous reprocher et lâcher sans
langue de bois c'est le temps
d'instruction qui aujourd'hui un qui a
quand même beaucoup diminué par rapport
depuis depuis les deux ans et demi que
je m'occupe de ce secteur de cette
compétence
maintenant nous avons quand même des
temps d'instruction qui sont tout à fait
supportable
il faudrait encore réduire si on veut
être il faut être bien mais aujourd'hui
oui il ya des réponses ils peuvent venir
il ya des dossiers sont sont remplies
sont déposés sont traitées au salon
comme celui là qui se déroulera du 30
janvier au 1er février ce sera pas juste
coup d'épée dans l'eau ce trois jours ce
suffisant pour bien s'imprégner de la
démarche de la méthode de ce qui existe
trois jours c'est suffisant pour booster
ta dire que là c'est vraiment je dirais
c'est l'amorçage du des bonnes pratiques
et puis pour savoir ce qui dans l'âme de
leyme de l'information savoir ce qui se
passe
alors vous savez que le salon le fait
tous les deux ans il faut il faut jeudi
il faut avoir il faut savoir mobiliser
donc le monde de l'entreprise pendant
trois jours
mais et après il ya il faut digérer
toute l'information il faut
véritablement mettra presse du contenu
puisque après pour qu'il y ait dans deux
ans qui dans les prochains deux ans qui
lie à nouveau un autre salon donc on est
vraiment je dirais ça va faire beaucoup
d'informations beaucoup d'initiatives on
va mettre en place du réseautage
il y aura donc des rencontres sur a dû
partager c'est vraiment je dirais je
vais pas dire c'est comme une fête quoi
mais tout pourra être vue concernant
l'entrepreneuriat pendant ces trois
jours et d'aude et à la fin nous allons
donner rendez vous dans deux ans parce
qu'on aura encore la possibilité de
revoir et de refaire et d'améliorer
l'offre que nous avons aujourd'hui
ressemble et que vous êtes passionnés
autour de cette question de notre père
n'a rien on rappelle que ce salon se
tiendra les 30 31 janvier et le 1er
février au palais des congrès de madiana
merci marine est avec nous dans son
crédit bonne journée